okay so
we have precious and her mom it's
patience oh why do i keep calling you
precious all right let me let me
everybody calls her precious oh my god
this is not the first time i've done
this right
everybody does it
everybody does even even at work today
latrice did it yeah it's easy to do yeah
all right let's start over again okay
all right patience
yeah and her mom alicia
so uh
welcome you guys
a lot of people are very curious about
what
patients mom is all about
and uh
i think this would be a good opportunity
for people to get to know
who you are and what you're
what you've been going through and what
you're doing and all this
so you guys have been living in a
motel or hotel for the last oh for the
last like week so since we since we shot
that video pretty much yeah yeah which
got you guys off this off of skid row
yes and we just got approved for our
housing so
another week or two at the most and um
we'll be in a two-bedroom apartment
yay far far from skid row far from skid
row very far from cedar somewhere in
north hills that's great good for you
guys yeah it's pretty exciting are you
excited patience oh yeah
she's excited she gets her own room
you can take your skateboard to a nicer
neighborhood yep
so a lot of i see the comments sometimes
on your video the first one with
patients and everyone's horrified as to
what this kid's life is all about
and all i can tell you because you
you're working seven days a week yes i
work all the time i see you working all
day every day and who's following you
she's attached to my hip she goes to
work with me i've never seen you guys
not
with each other yes and i i rarely see
you not working yeah i always work yeah
you're working non-stop at one of the
stores down the street
you walk past my studio every day yeah
um
and all i can say is i if i saw patients
and her situation was something that was
horrifying and needed to be
fixed i would scoop her up and do that
but but i see how well you take care of
her yeah i try my best i mean you're
going through a hard time right now and
i get that and that's where skid row
kind of comes in yeah but
you're doing your best to get off i'm
helping you a little bit and then yeah
the housing that you're giving for
everyone is going to help a lot right oh
gosh yeah yeah yeah it's a blessing it's
a total blessing
and then uh you know i've been
we're doing um registering her for
school on wheels for
you know kids experiencing homelessness
because
um
i've been in limbo so badly the last few
weeks you know school started and i
haven't i didn't know what to do because
i was being told we were going to move
into our place and then
then i was told it was only a potential
match and then it was it's just been in
limbo so i haven't known where to
register her at so i just decided forget
it i'm going to register her for school
on wheels and do the
homeless school until we get into our
apartment and then and then she can
transfer over
to a
a school
but now your apartment sounds imminent
right yes yes it's a definite it's a
definite thing it's definitely a
definite yeah it's it's been frustrating
for me to read all these comments
crucifying you when i know how hard
you're working and seeing everything
you're doing for your daughter
it's hard for me to read them too
i wanted to comment back but i'm like
forget it
no i mean the commenters can be
incredibly cruel and that's that's just
the nature of social media i think but i
i i knew that would eventually we would
be doing something like this that'll
kind of clear what's really going on mom
mom does a good job you think patience
yeah
you spend all your time with her right
yep at work i watch tv on the phone
do you have you ever been like in danger
of something bad happening here in skid
row when you've been with mom no
even though there's horrifying stuff
going on at every block but i don't
think this place is that scary
your mom has protected you nicely i
think i think all the people here nice
well it's good you're getting out before
you get to know too many people
yeah yeah no people um actually on the
block that we were staying on
the whole block um set up a jar for her
so if anybody walked by our tent and
cussed they had to put a dollar in the
jar or or else so i mean she she had a
good little fund
going for a minute and how are your
turtles they're doing good they're um
they're at home right now okay
and uh you guys
you know so we'll ride out the next week
or so
in a hotel yeah and then uh hopefully
your place in the valley
will become available and that'll give
you guys the housing that a lot of
people are getting now in skid row
yeah and you know they said it was uh
women and children first and it was
easiest to get into a place if you had a
child it's not true it was much more
easy if you were a single person i see i
see drug dealers getting apartments and
you and you're walking around trying to
get a place so
are you looking forward to going to
school
kind of
i'm looking forward to the math
it's her favorite subject yeah
and so alicia your history i mean you've
had a history with drugs
tell me about where you're at today and
well i'm sober today um but i've had a
i've had a long history of drug abuse um
yeah
my entire family um
and my mom
got sick um
and she she had cancer and um she
started
doing things and stuff too and um
this is in alaska yeah and she lost her
house and stuff and that's why i had
come back here originally when i did my
very first video was because i was
taking care of my mom and patients
that was when i was seven
i was sending them money every day
that's why i was here
making money to send to them every day
and then my mom just she was in
remission from her cancer
and she
just died
she had a
a stroke and had a brain aneurysm
and um
and she was only 62 and so i had to go
get patients like that night and i
wasn't ready
yet you know i was still here on skid
row but i had no other choice because
there was nowhere you know nobody to
take her
so
i had to bring her here with me which
was like the last thing i wanted to do
in the world would have her down here
with me
but um
thanks
but um
it's you know things have worked out i
got a job i work a lot
and and the cool thing about my job is
that they they understand what i'm going
through and they let her come to work
with me
yeah i don't see anybody working as hard
as you do on skateboard and the tree's
got a new kitten
the tree's got a new kitten the one who
works at the store the lady she got a
new kitten oh i see yeah which is
exciting for patients
but um
yeah it's all paid off i mean
what lessons have you learned from all
this craziness you've been through for
the last couple years
that this is not what i want for my life
or my kids life
you know i i definitely don't want to be
a role model that says that drug use is
okay i want to be the last person to
tell her that drugs are okay because
they're not they've ruined
my life and everybody but you know at
one at one point when my mom died i had
my son my sister i had patients
everybody up here living with me except
for shine but she should be coming with
her baby soon hopefully
anyway i had everybody here living
with me
and um and it was just it was hard for a
second and
patience is seeing firsthand you know
what drugs do
you know with her
with her brother and things like that
you know
and
he was her most favorite person in the
whole wide world and now
when i talked about him coming back she
was like no i started crying and i'm
like wow
you know she doesn't want to be
around
people like that you know patients you
see how destructive drugs can be
are you going to use drugs
are you going to smoke cigarettes
good good for you
and i don't think she will either
she's seen enough you know and at the
same same time she's been real sheltered
too she's
it's like
she's been exposed and sheltered at the
same time if that makes any sense yeah
no it's interesting
she's mix of being in the worst place on
earth and then yeah she's sheltered
still very much
an 11 year old like she's not
she's not a mature 11 year old she's
you know that's right you know what i
mean she's she's she's still a kid it's
not a race yeah
exactly
um
i think if if i had exposed her to
everything she could have been exposed
to out here she would be a lot different
yeah you'd be a very street smart kid
exactly
what i wanted useless a lot of people um
judge me on that because they think that
she needs to be more
aware of things going on and more street
smart but i want her to hold on to her
youth as long as possible
yeah keep her innocent get her the hell
out of here yeah which is exactly what
you're doing yeah trying by keeping her
under your wing all the time yeah and
then
she's with me all all the time she's
never
not with me ever
doing a great job mom thanks
all right well thank you so much for
coming by and
explaining what patience's
life is really all about
and your future looks great darling
thank you
thank you so much
thank you mark
you